à droite un problème furieux
c'est beau ça hein oui c'est bien parce
que l'outillage de face
soit lors soit la droite mais voilà il
brille par son terrier en fait non non
non ça voilà voilà voilà ils sont
adroits 10 soit trois heures passées
pour ségo c'est pas trois heures pour
venir à temps on voit là son bord deux
ou trois 3 heures là
voilà ils sont là presque sur l'autre
d'ailleurs été large chip à marlowe son
orgue et que cette rue marceau l'autre
voilà l'autre sens ralala cette centrale
la plus sacrée somme idiot ceglia y
allait y aller alors on tue des sceaux
ouais
s'apprête à peu dans sa les enfants eux
les tarifs vont remettre à 25 noeuds
pour les moines sur iphone puis tout au
plus le choix culturels un costume est
loin de jules au tout à l'égout
on sent il pas
l'heure de la terre
ce que je rencontre jour variés et voilà
ait milieu souffert voilà
les cônes ou patiner ou aller faire sa
sortie us
c'est au tour de la côte gauche comme ça
je récupère en large toute la toile
wemmel adapaté beauté ça fallait rester
à droite sont pas là tu restes sur les
abats grèce aussi on leur fait à temps
partiel abondamment parlé clairement
maintenant oui si tu ajoutes voila voila
c'est par là qu'il va commencer voilà
bon si on voit l'arrivée voilà effet que
tu peux remonter jusqu'à est en hausse
et je rigole
n'empêche que
car dans son discours doucement dans le
tour et voilà
pierre sa tresse concentre le centre en
route vers le médical
paris match
ouais cool sorte qu'on n'aurait pas pu
faire la centrale étaient en service
mais d'en être il perd on replantera
dernier coup droit tenant un dany côté
sarioglu
voilà ça va arriver comme la bicyclette
à l'heure
mais bon sang
c'est bien la femme appelle de sympathie
bord des larmes moi je veux voir la tour
en partant là à quoi
c'est lui qui est au dessus pour ce qui
a trait aux acquêts poésie donc voila
voila voila par l'horizon reste doit
s'en prendre l'horizon s'en prendre à
l'hôpital
places en vente dès maintenant
c'est vrai
et si peur ça allait super
patassé
un peu de terrain
quant à lui
sa peur la peur
on va aller sur le bras pour les ceux
qui sont en face parce qu'on avait les
brillances diplôme d'entraîneur dressé
dans l'action et non monter à dos à dos
à dos attendent la droite pour toi c'est
complètement brillant ouais mais que
pastor de batteur nathan pays 3 à 6 ans
avec lui ou l'un n'était pas sur le
monde et en face il faut aller voilà un
droit de vote aux azéris notre noyau
mais les oiseaux you will trop vieux
bouts labrieux regarde regarde un peu
comme ça brille de bande de moins qu'à
ranger le bordel
est on encore un
j'en prends plein la gueule mais ce
n'était pas assez de passer devant - non
non non non non non non non ne coûte pas
plus cher
j'ai pas savez tous pas je le rends pas
compte papin à l'express cette pêche de
laver les carreaux attend 100 foot sa
part lui rêve à s'apitoyer sa lentille
précise entre les bruits comme ça on met
en tension place il est doit le savent
bien
attention que le vers la borne robert
laborde d'aller en avant on a commencé à
tourner vers l'avant alors les hommes
dorment dans vers l'avant il faut du
gouvernement voilà à quoi ressemble leur
arrivée aux différents débats n'ont pas
produit
on a vu ce qu'a fait un petit pas grave
on voit là souvent de dos je mangeais
bon je vois rien c'est là où là c'est
bien c'est bien voilà le rayon abbas et
bien
je suis car plus un peu vers la gauche
et ouvrir à gauche voilà tout au plus
peut on peut le faire on va passer au
dessus voilà
c'est un peu violent drakkar est pour
rien c'est bon là on a un truc au sol un
ouais
de la dimension de travail apo / le
graphisme 20 me et je pense qu on va le
prendre l'autre auteur propose toujours
ses plus beaux airs ya l'ombre la wes a
peut être volé
atalante à le faire les et panneaux
après ta table à rabelais panneaux pour
plus beau je la tiens pas plus facile
j'aurais fait ouais c'est tard à presque
attention à l'ehpad
pensez pas qu'on m'appelle pas ne savais
pas
si la main droite à votre écoute ça va
aller l'as pensons ses propres concerts
tout ça la pâtisserie grand jeu par ok
on part de tricoter
t'as pas besoin
voilà on va de bon ton père d'avancé
je dis cela on n'ira pas au bras des
caennais
plus sur le graphisme l'ordre
allez on fera attention pas dossier
pas trop à droite
la limite entre les deux voilà c'est
bien le gardien verticale je fais monter
un peu à peu vers lagos voilà la langue
de l'élite face
voilà là on va tomber sur les gens
attention pas bien vertical qu'il
fallait titrait pour sa part est en
chantier
à ces griefs boîte à nantes avait aussi
le fils et le propos a dit que vraiment
belle fois que les colliers sombre et
les bâtiments c'est bien tu as bayonne
c'est bien là bas génial tu lâches fait
très bien map auteurs tous deux à
l'arrière voilà une voiture juste devant
dessous l'embrasser antilles c'est bien
parce que nous on voit bien le grand
dehors des trucs se vêtir un camion là
on va passer ses ordres de la loire à
camions d'histoire sur toi qui va
arriver là voilà tout le moins
maladroite irlande
voilà j'ai dit à génial génial voilà en
fait comme ça on va jusqu'au bout voilà
enfin voilà il ya truc
sans patente entre ce jour pas plus
d'arbres y aura bien robin revient
revient devant revient de baky des longs
ballons vers l'avant veille à traiter
pas tout à
on n'a pas fait le plan de tel que de
talent de resserrer voilà c'est ça qu'on
avait tout à l'heure à curieux jacques
adeler
voilà c'est ça voilà c'est tout voilà
voilà voilà voilà voilà
pas plus large
c'est bon c'est bon c'est avec un petit
break au milieu
génial voilà on se rend sort du truc de
travers complètement la pression
les coupes et ajustera c'est beau ça ça
tourne en est à situer suis tenté de
suivre la brillance qui fournissent ni
par faire beaucoup
le ca va défiler commencèrent savoir dès
qu'il est plus vite
c'est très fort